toute la semaine nous vous avons emmené
découvrir les tombes les plus illustres
des pays de la loire en vendée il en est
une qui attire chaque année des milliers
de pèlerins elodie soûlard et frédéric
un chèque nous dévoile son histoire
celle du père de montfort un prêtre
itinérant mort de fatigue voilà près de
300 ans
[Applaudissements]
saint louis marie grignion de montfort
repose dans la basilique de saint
laurent sur sèvre depuis le 29 avril
1716 de passage dans la commune
ce prêtre breton s'est éteint à 43 ans
mort de fatigue après avoir prêché près
de 200 missions
c'est un prêtre sans domicile fixe il
voyageait pour prêcher l'évangile
généralement est resté trois semaines ou
un mois dans une paroisse une fois
qu'ils avaient fini par tiger donc un
prêtre roux tard si vous voulez
il lui était très préoccupé par le désir
de transmettre dans un langage
accessible alors que probablement à
l'époque le langage du clergé était plus
ça d'aidé technique apps très petite
dose toxique et montfort et même toucher
les cas jusqu'à son dernier souffle
monfort a été adulé temps il était
populaire et donc on entre là droit mais
où chaque membre est décédé même sur son
lit de mort de laisser des gens pénétrer
dans la chambre les gens voulaient une
biguine où les toucher il y avait déjà
toute sa réputation de ça toute sa vie
monfort a porté son attention au soin
des pauvres à la santé et à
l'enseignement des enfants
quelques années après sa mort les trois
congrégations religieuses qui le
reconnaissent pour fondateur dans leur
mission
les filles de la sagesse les pères du
saint-esprit les frères de saint-gabriel
implantent leurs maisons mères au plus
près de son tango chaque année que vingt
mille pèlerins du monde entier se
recueille sur sa tombe et le plus
célèbre d'entre eux est jean paul 2 qui
est venue le 19 septembre 1996
le pape avait comme livre de chevet
depuis l'âge de 16 ans le traité de la
vraie dévotion écrit par montfort
première lecture difficile deuxième
lecture ça allait mieux
la troisième lecture il a gardé dans sa
poche jusqu'à son dernier souffle
ça a été le fond de la vie spirituelle
de jean paul ii ça a été vraiment
réunion m'enfin depuis trois siècles
l'histoire de saint laurent sur sèvre et
celle des congrégations n'ont cessé
d'être intimement liés d'où la création
d'un parcours découverte sur les pas de
mots forts il y a seulement un an
[Musique]